what's going on guys welcome to another
Python mathematics and stock indicators
tutorial video in this video we're gonna
be talking about how to calculate the
shake and money flow if you don't have
the sample data already so you haven't
maybe been following until this video
this is where you're going to get the
sample data that we're going to be
working with real quickly and that's
going to be some Dexcom slash sample
data dot tex just ctrl a ctrl C and you
have the data so come over here let's go
ahead and import numpy as an p import x
we're gonna need that and now let's go
ahead and open up that sample data file
so we're gonna say sample data equals
open and we're gonna open that sample
data dot text with the intention to read
it and then we're gonna go ahead and
read it in the memory then we're gonna
split that file so split data equals
sample data dot split whoops
split it by a new line then we're gonna
go ahead and do de close P hi P lo P
open volume equals NP dot lo text what
text we want to load we want to load up
split data the delimiter is gonna be a
comma
since it's a comma separated variable
list there and unpack equals true so we
can unpack all these variables next we
want to define seat hm lowercase o
capital F and the data that we're gonna
pass through here is going to be a d c h
au and au v and @ EF so date closed
high-low open volume time for anything
now we're going to start off with some
empty arrays let me make some more space
here so one of our empty arrays will be
CH MF maybe our trike and money flow
that we eventually returned our MF ms
that'll be our money flow multipliers
then our MF vs money flow volumes and
then X we'll start at time frame
now while X is less than the length of D
for date what do we want to do well
period volume world's say right now
equals zero but we'll start populating
that we're going to find wall range
equals V so volume is what we're
referencing that V data here V yeah the
X minus TF to the X variable so that's
the range of volume numbers that we're
going to consider and then we're going
to say mmm for each each volume in ball
range what do we want to do period
volume plus equals each ball so that's
that now what we're going to want to do
now is say MFM for money money flow
multiplier what we want to do is put
some parentheses and inside there add
two more parentheses and we're gonna say
basically it'll be C minus L for clutter
yeah close minus the low and then it's a
- hi - the close right then it was
divided by what the H line it or the
high - the L then the next thing we have
to do is we have to make this the X
variable in that array so I'm just going
to copy that and behind every letter
there you add X since it has to be the X
done MF v equals M FM oops I made that a
c MF v equals MF M times the period
volume and now we're going to say m FM's
got up and MF M then M IVs append m FV
and then we'll do our X plus X plus
equals one
and now we've done that so we've got the
MF mm but the MF v so step one and step
two is done but we still have to
calculate that shake and money flow so y
equals time frame and then a while y is
less than the length of just to be safe
we'll do MF V's reprise should do date
but that's okay we'll lose a little bit
more data on the end but again the
moving averages and stuff and the
starting point will make that not matter
so while that is the case again we're
gonna do period bought in fact what we
shall do is just a copy and paste right
here and paste it right there so we
don't the really do that so the period
volume stuff what we don't want to redo
that again so once we've done that then
we're gonna say consider so the array
that we want to consider now is MF ease
and again we're going to do y - time
frame : y so that would be what we
consider now and let's make some space
here and it's going to be TFS MF being
equals zero then for each MF v in
consider TFS MF V plus equals each MF v
so that's basically like you know like
this time time frames my flow volume
here now what we want to do is we're
going to say TFS cm F equals TFS money
flow vine divided by that period volume
and then finally we have our CH MF dot
append TFS oops that's lowercase TFS CMM
so time frames trike and line flow and
then this is just simply like shaking
money flow that we're appending up here
so now we finally need to do an X or a y
plus equals one and then at the end of
this we return date and we're gonna do
time frame plus time frame : and we'll
return see HMF
that way they're of equal length and
then CH oh what is the data we want to
pass through that it's like what's the
data we want like it's date close
high-level event so it's up typing that
all again let's just highlight this copy
come down here paste whoops not that
many days one page and then it will use
a time frame of 20 so what that's gonna
do is generate this with a time length
of 20 and then at the end of all this we
can just print see HMF just to see like
what if we get results that we think
look right so we can run that and I'll
just drag over the results so it looks
like you know about what we're looking
for right so the best thing now that we
can do is just plug it up and make sure
that's exactly what we were hoping to
achieve with our sheikin money flow so
in the next video that's what we be
doing if maybe I went a little too fast
in this video let me zoom out with a
smaller font here and talk again over
what we just did some long okay let me
pull up the that was the old image on
let me pull up the shaky money flow real
quick so the idea first is to find the
close - alone - the high - the close /
the high minus low so of course that's
what we did right here and that's known
as the money flow multiplier then step
two is to take that money flow
multiplier and multiplied that times of
time frames or the time frame periods
total volume so the way that we did that
was we've got that time frames total
volume with this thing right here right
it just adds it
all to period volume at each at each
step of the way so that's what we're
doing here so here's step two right and
this is also a sort of part of step two
but this is mostly your step two finally
you've got the third step which is going
to be the time frame sum of step two so
the sum of that for the twenty periods
basically which is known as the sum of
the money flow volume and they need to
abide that by that periods total volume
so that's what we're doing down here is
considering that sum and then we divide
it by the sum of the period here which
is right here so this timeframes cmf so
it's timeframes psyche and money flow
and then at the end of that we start we
append all of the psyche and money flows
and then we return all of the Jike and
money flows so hopefully that clears
that up if I went maybe too fast to do
that now in the next video what we're
going to do is actually chart this up
it's pretty simple to chart it up and
add it in there as you guys have
probably found so anyways that's what
we'll be doing in the next video as
always thanks for watching
thanks for the support of the
subscriptions and until next time